i know what you're doing frank you're
trying to make me lose my temper
but it's not gonna happen i'm afraid
cooler heads have prevailed
you're the devil in 2007 a film would be
released that would usher in a new era
of raunchy r-rated comedies and break
box office records it would ignite the
careers of several of its main stars
create a new genre of american comedy
and become an
instant global success that movie was
super bad
it's hard to overstate the general
success and positive reception of
superbad to this day
video essays sing its praises critics
recall it fondly and for many of its
actors they will always be remembered
for it but i'm not here to talk about
superbad
i'm here to talk about its disturbed
unloved little brother the film released
mere weeks before superbad stormed
theaters i'm here to talk about hot rod
[Music]
you see when i was a kid i was a little
too young to watch super bad i actually
remember
listening from another room as my
cousins congregated to watch it but you
know what movie i was allowed to watch
oh [ __ ] yeah a lot of people forget that
hot rod is pg-13 i forget it sometimes
too
fun fact that stunt was not supposed to
go that way the guy actually broke his
leg and they kept it in the movie
hot rod was the comedy that fined my
youth i found it like most people did on
a scratched up dvd one of my cousins
probably gotten walmart discount bin i
watched it late one night as my family
drifted to sleep on the couch i couldn't
believe what was happening on screen
part of me thought i dreamt it that
surreal feeling i had
was what people would one day call gen z
humor you know this kind of stuff
oh this is your former president barack
there's no
the stuff that the gen z is like it's
like yeah just a guy
screaming at the top of his lungs like
waving a gun around
in and out there's just no internal
monologue just
no planning nothing just pure id
zoomer humor is particularly known for
its being
anti-boomer in nature so what makes hot
rod so cutting edge how
is it anti-boomer why was it
unappreciated in its time
it's something of a miracle that hot rod
came into existence at all and we have
mostly lauren michaels to thank for it
after working only one year on snl andy
samberg akiva shaffer and
jorma tacona yorma norma tacon were
handed a script to rewrite sandberg
schaefer and ticone were known for their
lonely island sketches but they hadn't
yet had their breakout moment with lazy
sunday
basically lauren was taking a huge risk
on these guys hot rod was originally
written by pam brady as a will ferrell
vehicle they had to do a lot of work to
make it fit their voices
it was written for will ferrell so there
was a lot of great neptune's ghost
type lines that sandberg just doesn't
have the chops to pull off
and that makes sense if you cut out
certain scenes in the movie they could
stand alone as a digital short
who dave i like to party i'm rod no
you're kevin
right kevin i party no no
you don't okay nobody parties but me but
what elevates the movie is that perfect
simple touching story of an amateur
stunt man trying to get a heart
transplant for his dying stepfather just
so he can properly beat him to death i'm
not a kid
i'm a man i am gonna get you better and
then i'm gonna
beat you to death you couldn't beat a
drum
i mean the story itself is hilarious
which gave the lonely island guys free
reign to be as stupid as possible we
have a long history of people fake
pitching things
and then we say yes we're definitely
doing that kiva does it a lot
like we get a lazy pitch and we say oh
yeah that's perfect put it in
there's no real rhyme or reason to a lot
of the stuff in the movie yet it's not
random it's almost like there's a logic
of random there's a perfect balance that
has to be struck
for example in the original draft of the
script when rod is near death having an
out-of-body experience he meets evil
knievel we were like
we have to replace that because that
makes too much sense
hi
[Music]
you know one of the high points in the
movie happens immediately after the
inciting incident without warning the
movie becomes the greatest footloose
parody of all time
rod are you okay i need to go to my
quiet place
[Music]
then again without warning the movie
gives us the longest most painful fall
of all time
so what can we learn from that scene
pretty much nothing it is the essence of
gen z
humor while other shows and movies have
done this type of comedy no one has made
a movie that so
perfectly thrives off of this [ __ ]
that maintains this tone while also
telling a genuinely funny narrative the
reason i think this type of nonsense
humor is so enjoyable to the youths of
today it's because
we live in a world of non-stop
information non-stop calculations and
non-stop connectivity
gen z humor is like watching a brain
short circuiting
it's complete freedom from analysis
that's why i love hot rod
something about this movie just reminds
me of happier times
it's a funny story with a bunch of
nonsense in it
and that's just [ __ ] great you know
there's just nothing better than that
sometimes
it sure as hell doesn't get enough
recognition
[Music]
have fun being married to satan